happy Mother's Day hey everyone i'm abby
sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen if you
couldn't tell by my enthusiastic
introduction Mother's Day is around the
corner
and if there was ever someone in our
life worth celebrating it's our mom's
well dad's too but that's probably say I
mean who blew on your food to cool it
down while it was already in your mouth
who spent every day for three years of
your life cutting grapes in half and who
camped outside on Black Friday and
punched another parent in the face just
to get you a Fermi yep this woman did
she deserves a heck of a lot more than
some stupid drugstore card and since mom
has spent her entire life making sure
that we are well nourished on her day
it's time to return the favor so check
out my three edible recipes for mumsy on
Mother's Day first up my healthy oatmeal
cherry cookie mix for Bob to bake at
home I layer a cup of whole grain flour
a teaspoon of cinnamon 1/2 teaspoon of
nutmeg 1/2 a teaspoon of ginger a
teaspoon of baking soda 1/2 a teaspoon
of salt 2/3 a cup of dried cherries 1/4
cup of shredded toasted coconut 2 cups
of rolled oats 3/4 of a cup of brown
sugar and 1/2 a cup of white sugar into
a 1 liter mason jar next I decorate with
pretty ribbons adhesive double-sided
tape and send it to mom with a recipe
card that you can download off my blog
next up my dark chocolate chai truffles
these rich little morsels of heaven
combined 2 of mom's favorite flavors
chocolate and tea I bring a cup of cream
a tablespoon of chili leaves and half a
cup of butter to a boil in a saucepan
then I strain it over a pound of finely
chopped dark chocolate green and blacks
is my go-to chocolate brand for baking
and snacking because it's made with
certified Fairtrade organic ingredients
and comes in a wide range of fantastic
flavors I recommend the 70% for this
recipe because it's full bodied complex
and sweet once melted I stir the
chocolate until it's smooth then I chill
it until it's firm scoop it out with a
melon baller and roll it on a cold
surface into little balls next I
decorate it in cinnamon cocoa powder
crushed toasted almonds powdered sugar
and toasted coconut
finally I pack them into a little candy
box and decorate it up with pretty
ribbon and finally mom's healthier care
kick loaf I bake mom's favorite carrot
cake recipe in a paper loaf pan I'm
going to make a mom's day themed stencil
here
I print some words onto paper then trace
them with an exacto knife place it on
top of my cake and dust it with some
icing sugar finally I pop it into a
cellophane bag and tie it close with a
colorful ribbon so there you have it
three edible gifts for inspiring
delicious memories with the lovely
leading lady in our lives a big happy
Mother's Day to all the moms viewers
their moms and of course my mom - who's
watching at home thanks so much for
tuning in for more great recipes that
you can share with your loved ones be
sure to subscribe to my channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen
every week I power through five long
days of runs work emails errands and
chores and by the time Saturday rolls
around
I'm comatose on the couch in TV marathon
mode no big deal until the TV binge
turns into a full-blown junkie snack
binge sound familiar well we're in this
together
this is my snack confession here's all
my top tips to help you stop those
mindless munchies